a month-long meeting of Roman Catholic
Bishops from around the world is getting
underway this morning Pope Francis will
lead the gathering aimed at bringing
young Catholics back to the church Seth
Doane is in Rome where the Pope admits
many young people have turned away
because of the sex scandals that are
rocking the Vatican
Seth good morning to you good morning
even before this meeting begins it has
already been criticized by some church
leaders because clerical sex abuse is
not officially on the docket but it most
likely will loom large over these
meetings yes Pope Francis told bishops
this morning youth should have a future
free of the mistakes and sins of the
past today he launches the sin auteur
meeting which brings together nearly 300
church leaders from almost 125 countries
the Vatican has recognized young
people's lack of harmony with the church
so these mostly old people have surveyed
Catholic youth and will discuss topics
that sound like a teenager's google
history video games migration LGBT
issues war friendship porn and
corruption survivors of sex abuse are
taking advantage of this unusual
concentration of Bishops to speak up
these four hearing-impaired survivors of
clerical sex abuse pointed out the
priests who abuse them at the antonio
provolone Institute for the Deaf in
Verona Italy they plan to protest at the
Vatican later today I was naked and
confused Johnny B so Lee told us his
abuse started at age nine I was abused
in the confessional Giuseppe Concilio
explained when allegations surfaced some
of the predator priests from Italy were
transferred to another school for the
hearing impaired in Argentina where they
abused more children I would scream and
cry because of the pain Alessandro
ventini said but no one could hear me
because everyone was deaf those victims
told us that they would like the Vatican
to acknowledge their abuse in some cases
they would like to be compensated but
Norah they told us talking to the
Vatican was
talking to a wall Seth Doane in Rome
thank you I find that so upsetting it is
sickening and you can really feel the
pain just the fact that they were number
one that they're deaf and to be taken
advantage of that way I mean we all
gassed in the studio when he said I
would cry out in pain and no one could
hear me because their death it you deaf
you just don't think that that would
happen in a church setting and that
talking to the church is like talking to
a law this is why journalism and their
voices matter and that's Rome has got to
do something that Pope has got to do
something this is a time for him not
only to speak out they have got to
announce the reforms that they have
never announced and said that they would
and you know they've got to be
anticipating more of these types of
stories ahead really devastating Seth
Doane and the team in Rome there thank
you so much